leur objectif est clair trouver un
emploi ils sont une quinzaine de saint
quentinois a bénéficié de la nouvelle
garantie jeunes dispositif mis en place
par la mission locale et qui a pour
objectif de favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle
atelier numéric découverte de
l'entreprise ou encore aide à la
recherche d'emploi les jeunes sont
soumis à un programme intensif comme à
nice à 20 ans qui a stoppé ses études en
deuxième année de bac pro on a plusieurs
ateliers et des ateliers d'amélioration
de cv
il ya des êtres on est sorti sur paris
pour une journée d'intégration on est
allé voir le musée du louvre on a été
sur un bateau-mouche le fait en fait
d'être boostée par deux animatrices qui
tiennent ce dispositif le motiver à fond
avec elle et ça met de la bonne humeur
depuis début octobre les bénéficiaires
de la garantie jeunes sont suivis par la
mission locale et s'ils sont seulement
une quinzaine à en profiter actuellement
le dispositif devrait monter en
puissance progressivement car antigènes
c'est vraiment un dispositif totalement
nouveau ça renouvelle nos pratiques
professionnelles et on voulait pas
s'engager sur plus de jeunes on veut là
à voir un retour d'expérience au bout de
six mois à un an pour éventuellement
monter en puissance c'est possible en
tout 150 personnes devraient bénéficier
de la garantie jeunes sur l'ensemble de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'ils sont
assidus et investi ces derniers se
verront verser une allocation mensuelle
de 460 euros